while enca haider is in snowy canada her
husband is in a saudi prison if he
serves at his term rave badar we would
have spent 10 years behind bars for
writing a blog she's getting used to
dealing with journalists as part of a
campaign to try to save her husband
they're lining up to listen to her talk
and upset i heart I'm hopeful I really
am I expect the lobbying that is going
on now will yield results you guys here
I would like King Salman to grant my
husband a pardon and for him to be freed
your eye when is your life the two have
been together since 2001 after Badawi
was arrested for what he had written in
his blog in 2012 haider fled saudi
arabia with their three children they
were granted asylum in canada she's been
fighting for him ever since well I
Anello had that also fry for a huggle an
affair if I am to do rave justice I
would have to speak poetry to describe
him he's a very respectful person a
wonderful husband yeah he is the love I
always dreamt about the one I had in my
imagination and he is a compassionate
father Haider and the children only has
paretic contact with vid are we he's
only allowed to call them now and again
and not for long
lahaye Lamarr Wilson last I heard is
that his health is not good he has very
high blood pressure and I'm of division
and he's not doing well psychologically
either oh well they love superb and
muster at least Haider has support in a
new home she lives in sherbrooke a
couple of hours drive east of montreal
social workers have helped her to find
her feet your syllabus Kamal's our
services for in saps family started when
they got off the bus we help them settle
down look for an apartment register the
kids for school with their health care
and adapting to their new life so they
could enjoy a normal life as quickly as
possible through I paid more for suit
yet Haider situation is far from normal
her husband is in prison far away and is
to be flogged every Friday for months
but humble easier eyes I hope that the
rife comes back and can be with us with
his family that's all I hopeful take a
lemon it is that hope that inspires and
self Haider to keep fighting for right
but our wiis freedom